[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone
[Music]
I'd like to thank Persia and airy
[Music]
starting with
let's go
I went in the chat even before I even
started was so excited for this
[Music]
oh my god
testing testing one two three no mic
audio yet how about now
[Music]
there we go
how about now okay thank you guys so
much in the chat for helping me out with
that I think we should be good now but
keep it up with the comments if I'm too
low or if the game audio is too low
appreciate those there we go
all right whoo here we go Freddie
Mercury in the chat best game of all
time it's up there
the reason we're playing this any excuse
to play right but the reason I chose it
because it was our game spot of the year
it was our game of the year for 1998 and
tomorrow we'll be doing more with more
of game of the year stuff from the past
so we'll start with sprout here we go
thank you guys in the chat okay audio
sounds good let's go
what's going on chant a true classic yes
I was gonna start in kokiri forest like
just just that's where I was gonna start
the stream originally but I couldn't do
it you guys have to see the intro you
have to get into it just like me I'm so
excited oh yeah you guys like those file
names yeah hey there it is max what's up
this game needs the Resident Evil 2
treatment mm-hmm have you guys seen the
Finn the Unreal 4 engine like upgrades
to this game fans have started doing
that but nothing official from Nintendo
that's right doc watson this game was
reviewed by jeff gerstmann he's the one
who gave it to ten that year and made it
game of the year
no I did not name him link and in them
sprout you guys name you sprout that's
my nickname around here
[Music]
I love this you guys are flooding the
feed with all of your memories already
about this game keep them coming
this game is incredibly nostalgic in his
original review Jeff Guardsman was like
this is a game that people will be
talking about ten years from now and
here we are still talking about it 20
years from now
[Music]
there is look at that stash Yuri no it's
a blessing victory
[Music]
okay does that sound better that sounds
I hear myself now oh my gosh okay great
thank you Eric I think that's you on the
GameSpot account he tells my first time
doing this alone no Sam where are you
Bob Jones never played this game but
didn't have a 64 you know what I had a
similar story I had the the PlayStation
at the time so when this game came out I
didn't play it either
I didn't play until years later feel
like I missed out for sure oh yeah can't
wait for a Nintendo switch release of
this yeah thank you Eric thank you so
much once again shout out to John Luke
Eric and Sam for help me helping me set
this up this morning maxilla Chad's
waiting for Navi to to bump herself on
the fence right here it's coming max
it's coming eric is great right people
go y'all are like blame table ain't a
knob we need to a around here alright I
love this intro
[Music]
this is a great big mood right here you
have to save the world it's like no I
don't want to get up Nikolas said love
it getting this one on the 3ds was super
cool too yes it was a very good it was a
very nice treatment I wish it was a wish
I could play that easier on the big
screen that's up that updated version
but it's alright we're actually playing
this on the Wii Virtual Console the
original we this is one of the my
favorite ways to play it that music
[Music]
love for irritating the chat of course
yes
it's my crib time to dip
here we are max a little sprout yep
you remember that day max would wear the
chat dubbed me sprout I think we were
playing plants vs. zombies there's my
little girlfriend
man no weapons or nothing yep she dig me
[Music]
yes it is quite an honor
let's roll you're holding me up there we
go
Wow okay well you guys know I can't get
past what's-his-name over there without
a sword and shield so let's go find that
sword huh to this day the best gaming
soundtrack ah it's up there man love
this game yes feeling the love today for
this game always here we go I believe
this is the little maze area max keeps
coming serie is the best girl fight me
I'm with you man but she's just in my
way right now let's see roll yeah look
at that
speed run this now I'm kidding
[Music]
so nurse says one of the best games of
one of the best games ever oh yeah
[Music]
how are you guys yep be sure to practice
it's 20 years of practice actually let
me equip it
what Navi what do you want already
bugging me alright let's equip our new
toy huh look at that so empty I just
have my clothes a sword
Cheryl saver here we go everything all
the music all the sound effects
everything is so memorable in this game
that's just the best way to put this
game I'm already in in credit in an
incredibly nostalgic person in this game
just like fits the bill and like I said
earlier I didn't even play this game at
lunch it still has that power to make
someone so nostalgic even though I
played it like geez at least 10 years
after launch
probably more hey don't like that
swinging
all right what does he have to say I
forgot this guy's name they all look the
same here all these they have the same
like haircut there's three brothers that
look like this they're all triplets oh
okay this guy just wants to train a Z
target
i'ma pass I only have an hour and a half
here here you go one way to get the
shield which is what I'm gonna do is
just make a little money here you can
find it for free later but nah plus when
you do find it later you can't get past
this guy right now I need to get past
this guy who's blocking the door are
blocking the entry whites of the Deku
Tree I don't have any money what are we
doing I'm running into the shop like I
own the place not yet there we go
money
[Music]
they should remake this in majora's mask
and the breath of the wild engine roof
not saying no to that I love this game
so much any iteration I'll play I bought
it on the 3d s2 Majora's Mask though
what do you guys have thoughts on that
game let me know in chat it's a very
polarizing game I like Ocarina of Time
more there's a lot to like about
Majora's Mask
but in the end operating of time takes
it funny
come on no money no money okay there is
a lot of ways to make quick buck around
here slicing shrubs and stuff like that
let's uh although I forget how much the
shield is let's see I think it's like 40
rubies
let's check the stores right here oh man
no I know who's up there
I don't have time for this camera says
love Majora's Mask also Josh love
majora's mask there you go
see I knew we'd have fans in here talk
to the owner
this kid is the owner all right it is 40
rupees I was right I didn't have to come
in here whatever crime says majora
majora's mask
[Music]
look I don't have a jar oh that's his
fairy Isles I don't have a jar yet there
we go
[Music]
give me your money
no money Riley says I haven't played any
other Zelda game so I can't really form
an opinion that uh that happens you know
I haven't played a lot of titles myself
like big ones like this so whatever it
happens but I hope you're enjoying the
stream thank you for joining anyway and
this game you should definitely try out
if you ever want to jump into a Zelda
game this one is very good one of the
best come on I just need 12 more bucks
12 more rupees hmm oh yeah these are
these little shrubs here respond and see
if I can make some more money we're
getting there this is the hustle guys
the grind is real there we go 10 more
wait isn't there uh I think I can get
some rupees on this how am I sitting by
the way okay good I'm in frame I don't
even take time to notice such a rookie
ooh yes okay I was saying around here I
think if you swim you can make rupees or
if you make these sick parkour jumps you
get rupees what am I thinking no what's
up all right let me try swimming maybe
it's only in front of the castle where
you can get that cool the bonus for
swimming for rupees what am I trying to
save money for swimming only in front of
the castle I think
there we go four more bucks let's go the
grind never stop Joe
ooh that's for later you don't know what
that is this jerk I think I've seen
those speed runs where you can just like
Juke past them or like glitch past them
I love doing that and I can't do it I
love seeing that come on Oh what am i
doing I should go in people's houses and
break pots uh that's not enough rupees
not yet IDN wait gotta get that you get
that other optional view just hearts no
pots this place is a dump it is 40
rupees yeah we're getting there
look at that three more bucks three more
rupees is this a homestead with pots is
this the Krusty Krab no this is the shop
go go go
didn't mean to do that okay there's a
house so maybe uh let's read the sign
outside of this place I think this is
the house I'm thinking of there you go
in there already
Rob sorry I'm serie hey you guys there
she is
okay we're getting there
two more dollars two more dollars
I carry says best game made dang bold
claim not gonna fight you on it though
it is up there
reason we're playing is because it was
our game of the year in 1998 and any
excuse to play this game is fine by me
okay
sick of looking for money let's get this
over with huh one more dollar yeah let's
go get that shield tell that fool to
Frick off I always forget his name they
all feel silly little four-letter names
in this game but the guy blocking meat
oh no I don't remember
I don't big surf in the chat best game
ever so glad you guys are in on this
like this game is wonderful and it's
great that everyone feels the same way
talk to the oh here we go
okay you said that already bro yeah it's
time to get broke there it is
[Music]
okay okay okay yeah yeah enough with the
I don't have any money don't ask me that
okay time to equip this look at that
again just so empty I'm so young on my
journey here great how many do you guys
look good
no moving on oh there is everyone in
this town makes fun of me because I
don't know fairy now I do out of my way
yeah yeah yeah I have both move the
Kokiri sword they're like they're like
you're borrowing this make sure you
bring it back you never bring it back it
is yours
out of my way it's time y'all who are
you guys listening off your top 10
Zelda's top 10 Zelda's into the chat
whoop me top 5 there's so many though
this Eddie B this is on the original Wii
I'm playing the version I bought years
ago on the Virtual Console all right we
got sticks wait okay flip chick chop
jump chop check you dead
oh right huh enough
well I can't equip these now at least
wonderful oh my gosh
max you and me both gerudo valley best
music for sure oh my god that's my oh my
god
yep 100% agree I love that that guitar
Oh sprout that's me
Eddie beat you're welcome I hope you
have it on the Wii because now you can't
buy this on the original Wii or even the
Wii U and you want to remember but you
know they closed the shop
but this is still one of my favorite
ways to emulate the game and it's legit
that's through Nintendo okay
this wind bag is yakking on and on okay
looks like my dad with that mustache
well [ __ ] looks like me with that
mustache now that I have one yeah yeah
we know that we know what's up
that's ooh
best theme goes to sheep okay I'm not
gonna fight you on any of the music you
guys have all your opinions and they're
all right because this game just rules
I'm going around getting some more
sticks before I yeah forget him no need
to waste time right yeah mr. sensible
you know we all know what happens the
Deku Tree he did he gonna die but this
is our last adventure with him and the
beginning of our journey
whoa ah all right I'm gonna cut the
stream it's over bye guys I was too
excited I rolled the wrong way max wants
a mustache face-off I don't know Oh
rookie look at that I'm ready to green
ha
what okay maybe I don't even fight
everyone I just want to look around in
peace there's the web by jumping okay
Navi there's a lot going on here I'm
being attacked and Navi still wants to
talk to me full-on health okay I could
use money though so I'll be slicing
these shrubs everywhere I go oh my god
stop
okay fine I have to yeah I have to stop
and be like okay think back to the first
time you play this if you didn't I mean
I would have figured it out but think
for think of the kids when you see those
little info things pop up am I tired
I'm pulling I'm yanking the plant there
we go ooh okay I don't have anything to
fight him yet what is this a compass
liquid says breath the wild out and 2021
hmm you got a map they even make the
maps a big deal got a lot love it or
hate it
it's Zelda baby y'all are here for a
reason
thank you all by the way for joining Lil
ol me by myself
her jaw is on a flight to Japan that's
crazy
whoa you know it's serious oh shoot
there we go I'm ready I'm ready with my
shield gonna take your spot got him I
don't look just like that I'm his master
what are you gonna do yeah yeah thanks
for the tip buddy mario64 best game best
Mario game ever says liquid 8:v it's up
there for me I like Super Mario World
and I think a very close second is Mario
64 Wow
[Music]
how am i doing am i scooting away no I'm
good
I keep shuffling around because we have
a different uh setup today because this
is a four by three game so we haven't
more room for me and only me did it go
that's me no we're not gonna play the
whole game today is just a regular
regular hour and a half stream but stick
around tomorrow we're playing more games
of the year from our past tomorrow is
GTA 3 y'all mm one's game of the year
actually you know this game shared game
of the yellow in 1998 this game was the
video game of the year and then the PC
game of the year we also had that that's
when we had two categories back in the
day so it was all Korean of time and
grim fandago for the PC guys remember
that game I didn't get into PC so much
later ah shoot
might as well make some money here
got'em got'em okay thank you thank you
need a slingshot okay wait let's check
double check coming you haven't picked
that up yet losing my mind y'all I did I
did just pick it up I was running my
mouth here we go yeah that's the way to
get out of here
sure
let's save ha ha oh I cancelled out okay
this is Looney Tunes yay
[Music]
Thomas says our Tomas says the fact that
I played this game on Christmas 21 years
ago scares the [ __ ] out of me
whoo I played it a little later but I
was a young lad when it came out to that
time is just catching up y'all
whoo there Crump says there are rumors
that Grim Fandango might come to xbox
y'all got the Xbox okay now that I have
a slingshot take these fools out they're
not they're not even golden guys these
scrubs on the scrub here there we go
safe to climb up boo money rubies about
eight says forgot how beautiful this
game is mm-hmm
oh man forgot one I can't go crazy all
right I'm gonna try to just oh she's
[Music]
such a long fall uh all right fine
you'll pay for that I said you'll pay
for that eventually you will pay for
that there we go
oh man I wanted his rupees whatever
forget him
[Music]
movie guy the chat have you watched
scarface it's been a few years but ya
seen it that for me for the chat whoa
whoa okay here we go wonderful oh
there's the big one big boy exposing his
weakness right there zap get out of my
face there we go okay I'm gonna double
check for any rooms up here before I
make the grand jump down the spider web
I think there is a room yeah whoa
death by spider says Bob Jones yet don't
want none of that okay there's one
chillin over there there's the torch
there's and this is my boomstick all
right
let's figure out the puzzle here yes
[Music]
oh that let me out okay I don't need to
do that Oh crud whatever that's one way
to get rid of your stick that on fire
here we go ooh there's a gold Skulltula
down there first away I think this is
the compass they're hyping it up is just
the compass I think I already got the
slingshot yeah Tonya says this was my
favorite Zelda I still have it and my
n64 very good this is also my favorite
breath of the wild came very close to
taking the throne but every time I play
this I get a very special feeling that
breath the wild can't even he gets close
but it can't get it's probably not old
enough you know in ten years I'll be
like goddamn breath little wild was
dansgame but for right now I'm still
ocarina is my favorite ocarina whoa all
up in my face I'm wasting Emma I could
just chop him when he's flipped around
am i doing no money whoa oh yeah hey
enough watch this you're gonna die oh I
missed again this this little enemy this
basic-ass oh that's what I meant earlier
when I said nerds are you playing on n64
no I am playing on the Nintendo Wii
check it out y'all remember this
yep I was telling chat earlier oh man I
was telling chat earlier it's probably
my favorite way to play since I don't
have like the cool setup for the n64 at
home we do have it in 64 at home here we
go
came here for you dude you gonna die all
right
these ones take two hits I might just ya
know what why did I do that so impatient
yeah yeah yeah thanks
great this is what I want oh yeah yeah
we are we are playing on the the
original we remember when this was for
sale on the Virtual Console mmm
downloaded it all those years ago that's
how we're playing today okay did I miss
any other doors here I think I have
everything here that's where I came from
all right time to jump down y'all y'all
know what's up oh man I meant to take
the sword out whatever he's gonna die
yeah wonderful
okay I only have 10 after all this time
I only have 10 rupees yeah oh oh what a
fall what a fall whoa no you get your
block huh there's a Z target huh there
we go
[Music]
ha man you guys tell me of your first
memories with this game mine
like I mentioned were very late I had
the PlayStation 1 so I did not play this
game I didn't have the n64 at launch I
didn't get until much till years later
missed out on a lot
oh man what did I do that I don't have
the I gotta make that jump
alright let's see if I can do it okay
I'm cool
no biggie alright I gotta go up the
little puzzle here involving five years
there we go
but yeah tell me how you guys got into
this game or have you ever played this
game I have to make this jump I forget
no bueno okay now I wasted a stick
ah dang it I really blew it
alright I have to light all the the
spiderwebs around here and the torches
we'll see the best way to do it okay
I can't get to that side yet I remember
that I can climb back up there okay so I
have to get across here and light this
on fire
okay well that's too deep right there
how do I get the fire across
okay can I make that jump how are you
I forget how you're supposed to do this
gosh dang it oh it made some money on
the side here
okay that gold skulltulas bothering me
OOP missed it Oh missed it again whoops
my finger slipped there we go climb for
here and pick that up
okay I'm just trying to figure out how
to get the fire across or do I come back
to this later
once I do get to the other side yeah I
can't go up here yet I'm hearing music
though someone wants to fight me over
there all right for now I'm gonna climb
back up
quit falling
about eight says was like four or five
years old my dad had completed it for me
I just remember running around the
Hyrule town area oh yeah that game was
probably more for your dad huh
I'll take over son I'll help you out
here and then he finishes the game right
I didn't uncle like that I mean but I
did want his help because I was very
young and didn't know how to play many
games then I got better okay
[Music]
whoa nope well got him okay well I don't
want to leave here without the what I
came for I forget what it's called a
little the green thing but I'm just
trying to figure out how to get to the
other side of that area I try to jump
here okay that doesn't work and now
there are bad guys again let's see
well I'm 47 when I grew up with Atari I
love video games ever since uh as old as
your favorite franchise I bought a
switch and how to play breath of the
wild yes glad you did I hope you enjoyed
that game too a lot of us here in the
office love it it's great wonderful game
[Music]
guys I think I'm gonna need your help do
I deal with this at this moment or do I
come back to this later I can't get I
can't get this fire this torch to the
other side without falling in the water
oh never mind I know what to do yeah
there's a little path here that's just
just there we go just small enough for
me to jump just short
[Music]
Chamorro says the mass request of this
version is great yes it is switches
things up just enough it doesn't piss
you off but if you're way too used to
this game the Master Quest of this game
is pretty great gotcha
got him no well not your master just
want to get by you bro wood mouse hello
thanks for joining all of you guys
thanks for joining me today Sam is out
she is on a plane to Japan and I'm
taking over solo appreciate guys
appreciate you guys being here we're
playing our some of our games of the
year throughout the years this was the
game of the year in 1998
tomorrow we will be playing GTA 3 and
the next day we will be playing this
year's game of the year
sticky row so stick around we are here
every weekday oh man oh just that last
there we go come on mmm Ryan the I got
him cheesy B yeah I figured it out just
at the last second I was about to give
up okay that's how I came in making some
money here let's go
gzb also says this game reminds me of
the dawn of 3d gaming yeah oh man
everyone got the 3d treatment the
makeover this time it was an exciting
time for sure I was more on the
playstation side of things but you can't
deny the impact the n64 had in general
what I gonna do duck oh no [ __ ] I gotta
clear the water out and get hit dive
dive dive
I missed the button no I got it
[Music]
Tristan says hello I love this game this
is my favorite Zelda game of all time
same dude thank you for joining us today
hope I'm doing it some justice we my
girlfriend and I play this we try to
like every year it's one of the video
games she actually enjoys oh so she's
actually I believe she's the one who
introduced this to me after watching
babe Thanks what am i doing me my sword
there we go
[Music]
okay this fools gotta go first
hi-yah oh wait
one of the silliest enemies this guy if
anything is more of an inconvenience to
see them like just move okay ah she's EB
remember bubsy 3d oh my gosh we're not
going there
about eight says did double seven golden
I ever get game of the year no I believe
it was the same year as this and that
says something I would double check
golden I might have been ninety-seven
but I think it wasn't 99
I'm sorry 98 push yes
climb okay I had to push it what am i
doing the one the one time I didn't like
listen to Navi crime says goal denied
for sure got Game of the Year I think I
doubled for this list and when I was
coming up with the games to stream I
looked on our our previous games of the
year I'm not sure if it made it may be
for another outlet but maybe worth
double-checking here we go okay I'm just
surrounded now hmm what that was a clear
head I'm still whipping it what's going
on here I guess I have to hit their
heads there's one I just want to clear
the room keep it quiet around here come
on do your thing okay am i doing waiting
around haha okay
room clear yes
Goldeneye was 1997 dude okay
well that's good I'll double-check I
solved the list right here on my phone
of our games of the year I wonder if we
made it that year wonderful ah crime he
said I meant for me ah yes of course
crime man came in here for me in 1997 I
gotta think back that was one of them
for sure
again I'd even have it in 64 but the
impact was made every time I went to a
friend's house and we'd play that hell
yeah unforgettable whoa man
[Music]
okay I'm just gonna stand back here and
handle it with muscling shot Bart
Simpson style that was ridiculous okay
look I love that flip
although whoo yeah should have stuck
with the z-targeting there huh how are
we doing Chet what was your game of the
year this year iris was sick your oh how
about you there were so many games this
year I'm getting bored whoa okay time to
get serious
man they take more than one hit no they
don't
okay forgot these guys were in this room
sorry my z-targeting button up here the
Z L is a little squishy for some reason
this sucks no excuses
got him
now will the room open up what would I
have to do now
no I have to burn that okay there was
something creeping around here there it
is in the shadows maybe [ __ ] I just ran
into it she shouldn't be doing that
Randall asks have you ever 100 percent
of this game oh yeah oh yeah that's I I
I'm in that mindset like if I loved a
game i binge play it until I Platinum it
and that that mentality started many
years ago and this was one of the games
or I tried to do that looked up I looked
up a guide after I finished I was like
oh no I need more like let me get all
the heart pieces let me finish this game
shizzi be with the with the nostalgia
here remember to bottle number one yeah
Tobel how do you guys say I always
forget show so much I played that game
but I do remember it whoa man I keep
trying to go around them after they buy
me it's not working and I'm gonna lose
my health
okay now I'm in the area that I need to
be in this was the other side of that
little Canyon area
come on come on there we go come on give
me some hearts no only give me sticks
that's right did the original Tarak ever
get game of the air asks about about
eight no I don't believe now with us I
don't believe whoa yeah there were a lot
of great games on the n64 huh Chris L
says there can only be one game in the
air you're right man okay let's push
this dumb thing not climb No there we go
grab we're getting there y'all the Deku
Tree is near completion
crime yeah I stopped having games of the
year after what's he say after too many
yeah there were too many good games out
in one year I hear you man this guy came
back I just want the fire up there all
right going for it yeah love doing that
well let's reach what oh boy
well I moved the boulder for a reason am
i right y'all now I can go get that fire
come back
such an innocent little puzzle yep
now blew it actually do we know I don't
jump into this one doing I'm supposed to
use the fire how do I know I don't want
it the slingshot stop stop stop
uh okay I should have used okay you jump
through there using fire pretty sure but
I need to grab it from the other side
okay let's try this again
she's EB I don't know man I don't know
if we'll ever do it to a ball total play
Oh played through Oh
I mean if they're I would love to it'd
be fun to revisit that game I don't know
I don't know if it's in the cards my
friend all right now what what am I
doing here swing this right yeah I
almost it almost went out still got it
yeah stone it you want me to roll
I do love rolling in this game like when
I'm fighting when you mean are you like
you like that sound if I calm huh yeah
all right it's the three triplets time
they're gonna throw their stupid see
Demi let's get ready we all know the
order right two three one no [ __ ] come
on quit bother bullying me two three
come on he's still frozen let's go three
oh my god don't even hit him it didn't
even hit him there we go
I'm not using what the game's giving me
here we go kanabi calm down I got this
yeah taking your spot I am the third
brother
how did you know cuz your brother is a
snitch bro so annoying
I love that line he's like he's not like
I'm gonna kill you he's like you're so
annoying when I was young most games
when I'm reading the chat now catching
up with you guys thank you all for being
here here we go
[Music]
we play Metroid Prime know our lineup is
as our lineup is from today to Friday
and our games of the year I will be
playing or this gta3 tomorrow and then
hopefully I can get David on the stream
for Friday and we can play second row
because y'all don't want to see me play
that I didn't play it this year David
did he's the man and you guys would
laugh at me if I try to play that game
we were talking about that earlier
someone in chat was like I never I never
played a Zelda game I never played a
souls game I never played a blood-borne
I never played demon souls I never
played any of them I don't want to jump
in a sec bro because uh not yet I kind
of when I first heard about it I was
like okay I kind of want to go back oh
you know what it's boss time we'll have
story time later it's boss time right
now looking at my z-targeting practice
my boom my slingshot out it's time to
fight this fool Rizzy I have to look at
for him don't I so dark I see his
eyeball you there oh
crime yang better get David yeah man
that's not a that's not a game you guys
want to see me innocently play for the
first time SEC your oh you guys and I
would - I forgot everything I learned
just kidding
come here you little a little one two
here one
Oh he closed his eye okay I got to get
my rhythm right blink blink blink open
no I'm wasting like there we go yeah
hmm gonna like jump on these of you oh
yeah I got that backflip though oh cool
I don't even have to let him do his
thing
yeah geez how does he not get crime you
should try them yeah I do want to I just
wanted to start with demon souls and get
the get the the whole experience from
the beginning I wanted to appreciate
sake euro from by playing the other
games first that's just that's why I
don't get into a lot of games actually I
don't start them because I'm like oh
well I want to play the first cake first
that's just me being a goof and I have
an incredibly long backlog roxelle says
I've never played an insulting game
either I don't find the appeal I
appreciate you tuning in
having said that but if you like what
you see this is one of the games that's
it's so important I think you should
give it a shot if you're at all
interested I can see how the series
might be overwhelming seemingly
overrated but this game don't sleep on
it please yeah we do whatever you want
okay sleep on it
buy a copy and just go to sleep on it
there is this old windbag he's like hey
oh you did it I'm dead no crime suggest
starting with breath of the wild
oh I mean what are they oh that's
alright if I say no he'll be like listen
up anyway I'm gonna tell you a story
yeah wonderful I that's cool you played
you got it you picked up the game for
the first time a little after launch and
then you played it throughout 98 and 99
hell yeah do I have the bow yet no I do
you only you only get that as at a dull
and I'm a child I only get the slingshot
as little link Kenny says the 3ds remake
is especially good for a first
first-time playthrough yes absolutely
and they reprinted it so like for a
while there weren't rare but no one sold
their copy on the 3d is the original
print so they were a little hard to find
not rare but just no one was giving them
up you can buy it digitally now of
course on the 3ds or you could they
reprinted it as like a best sellers
choice whatever they reprinted so if you
want to play on the 3ds yes this game is
available there we are playing on the
wii today aha look courage wisdom earth
fire wind water to Anna Soros Chris says
I loved my NES and Super Nintendo and
played most of the classics but never
could get into Zelda sorry man
appreciate you yeah I want to reinforce
I appreciate you watching even though I
you couldn't get into Zelda hopefully
you like what you're seeing here this
game is fun it's wonderful but if you
yeah in the SNES days it was was really
strong the whole Zelda series because
that's when Link to the Past came out
everyone loves Link to the Past
I think right yeah Kenny also this game
on the 3ds is only 20 bucks after the
reprint it is officially 20 bucks you
can probably find it cheaper now to this
version we're playing here on the we've
no longer available was the Wii Shop
closed down yellow happen F's in the
chat for the Wii Shop
there it is the goddesses that made of
the Triforce okay
this is important backstory for sure but
these cutscenes are unskipable you know
it's fine a little time to talk chat
with y'all
hydrate with my Reptar thing
mmm-hmm yes absolutely thank you and
Tristan for the F and J oh you guys that
was a good time like the we was also
very polarizing like it changed the way
you did but I had a great Virtual
Console it's it's my emulation machine
that's what I used it for most and Mario
Galaxy look I would say like there were
definitely good games but I used it
mostly for to play the old ones come on
look he was sitting he was so bored he
took a seat
yes I have played this before if you're
asking me Justina about the this game
yes oh I love this game
there it is I got it now this trees
finally gonna die and that's okay he
served his purpose right
go ahead and spend more eps for the
great Deku Tree
coheeries emerald for a sec I forgot it
was called there's three of these
that's my name sprout Navi the fairy yes
yes yeah oh now he's he's dying
Oh No good bye it's over there it is oh
man
Chris elmeshad says we was the most
successful gaming gimmick of all time
yeah
it bought into like you know families it
did a great job and made millions for
Nintendo for a lot of reasons it was
like you know all the Wii Fit all the
things families could enjoy together and
the whole motion control thing gimmicky
or not I love this thing and playing
retro games emulator with this thing oh
man now this guy's in my way again
I just I'm saving the world like get out
of my way bro now he thinks I killed the
great Deku Tree I'm gonna slice in half
man he just dipped what a jerk
okay now I can just leave I can leave
here it's time for a Hyrule Field y'all
get out of my way
you guys remember the first time you
played this and you entered Hyrule Field
the wonderful music oh you know what I
think
serie tries to stop me and give me the
the first ocarina
ah
yep here she is Jess sir I'm trying to
say that right appreciate it though all
these all these beautiful names I can't
like I can't hang sometimes but I
appreciate you where you guys from
that's another thing I love to do I'm
chat sometimes you guys will randomly be
like hello from Brazil oh hello from
here hello from there that's incredibly
fascinating to me I'm here on the west
coast SF time oh we have a half hour
left okay just checking in but yeah
shout it out in the chat where you guys
from were you guys viewing this from
today there it is the first ocarina you
guys get yes yes I know what to use it
come on I wanna go home field I love
this like after she gives you this
wonderful tool that you need to play the
game with you like kind of just scurry
off cuz you're an embarrassed little boy
I think it's about to happen yeah he's
like thanks bro can I get a your number
or something by Ramone from Mexico I am
the one from Houston Texas Yeah right
hello from Chile man this is Gracie this
is I love seeing that hello from London
England man
[Music]
South Africa Nashville Venezuela you
guys got to be kidding me this is great
I don't know why I think we're just like
I just localized to like I don't know I
don't know why I think it's only like
northern North America but this is great
this proved me wrong also but wait
there's a way to skip this I not skip it
but fast-forward there's a button
combination I swear
whoo I did it yeah oh yes I did
now you can go away hoot hoot hoot whoo
hello from the UK Oak Harbor Washington
yeah Missouri the Netherlands and thank
you guys from from tuning we got people
from all around the world love it here
we are
Hyrule Field yes so memorable oh hell no
mm-hmm I'm not ready I'm too small from
Sweden from Canada this is great hope
you guys are enjoying the stream
[Music]
official bass or bass merchant says I'm
from the Dark Side of the Moon gotcha
bro bad reception though SoCal says
Chris all right what up Italy no that's
not that's not true and I want to I want
to say la is all SoCal does not equal
I'm sorry la does not equal all of safe
now
but SoCal's wonderful can't wait to go
back fighting these guys picking on me
making some money first order of
business I think we're gonna go to town
sorry I'm not z-targeting because I like
doing this spinny move that's the best
alright alright quit picking on me
skeleton dudes Chris L from Raccoon City
you wildin quickly you'd want to be
there actually 1998 when this game came
out that was the worst time to be in
reckon city that's when it happened
viewers from Germany oh yeah whoa ah
come on
oh you guys seem like if you keep
fighting these yeah how they get bigger
like this I forget what the biggest
sizes but I forgot I was watching some
YouTube video and if you keep
consistently fighting them like this I
get pretty large yeah see Chris that's
what I was trying to avoid I hate when
people say from the base a socal zealot
yeah it's yeah there's so many towns in
all of Southern California there are a
lot of towns in Los Angeles County but
there are so many towns in the second
the southern half of Southern California
it's nuts you don't have to be from LA
to be from SoCal here we go
one of my favorite characters in this
game is coming up he's just a regular
ass guard who doesn't give two shits
about his job there is he's like hey
whatever you want
[Laughter]
fire guard yeah that'd be me as this is
me as a guard it's a big mood here he's
telling me to break pots I love it make
some money here I think I only go to 50
right now 50 rupees
no 100 cool Oh 99 this is wonderful
hide your pots had your vases link is
here yeah mmm headbutt these boxes but
no money
Oh lift it I'm not trying to talk to you
are you yeah
whoever forgot about this guy all right
takes two hits I'll just shoot him with
this thing to be safe there we go yeah
all right there we go remember later
when you're an adult this becomes like
that cool go shop and have a look at the
best tunes ooh I wonder if yep that's
his ghost right that's the spirit guy
that weird guy in the you'll see him
later
no you won't this this stream is gonna
end in about 25 minutes
I don't think I'll make it to adulthood
by then I've seen I've seen speedrunners
do it but nah we're playing for fun
nostalgia not for speed this guy looks
like a robber cat burglar tough late
I've heard that before right that's the
white rabbit all right what am i doing
um can i buy the shield
I think it's 99 rupees yikes
Zangief over here run the shop it's 80
rupees okay good to know I'm very close
maybe I can go back and break some more
putts make some money oh come on
there we go
[Music]
there's the mask shop we all know plays
a small role in this game but plays a
major role in majora's mask we talked
about it a little bit earlier but how do
you guys feel about Majora's Mask even
more people have joined in the chat very
uh either love it or you hate it type of
game very polarizing ah look young love
maybe not she's kind of clowning on me
yeah but she is the key to Epona later
fairy boy yeah okay you see okay my
first order of business it was nice to
visit the town for a sec I'm gonna go
get a little more money get my shield
and it's the next move after that I
think I have to go to Kakariko village
yeah what's my favorite weapon in the
game hmm the Master Sword is of course
iconic but I think once you fix the big
goron sword that's the best you just
swing it around you can't even rock a
shield because it's so massive I think
that is my favorite weapon yeah I'm rich
Francisco says I love Majora's Mask
there you go I am mixed on it I wanted
to love it so much but I couldn't get
into it it's kind of a rookie thing to
say but like the whole the way you play
through time and how time runs out and
you rewinding time I couldn't get into
it I'd really try it I even followed a
walk through
but I love the music I love the
characters it's still a fun game to play
but I don't know not as much as this
that's all I'm trying to say yeah okay
Oh max out oh my let's get out of here
yeah yeah all right where we going
Oh shield uh
look at these two gossiping away all
right where's the shield shop
zenki store that's right am i doing my
sitting okay doing fine talk to the
owner or quit hot seller is a hilly in
Joo hey I'll buy it might be too big for
you kid although it's funny when you do
block with this shield you duck you know
you don't you don't block and duck no no
lamp ropes bombs lamp oil but exam
I didn't even equip this yet I haven't
learned any tunes ah okay time to equip
the new shield hell yeah Ramon says my
favorite Zelda game is breath of the
wild it's a good one it's a great one
that game hmm it's so much right okay
let's go back ah shoes I supposed to
talk to someone before going to Kakariko
village yeah I'll just go oh I could
make friends with Epona I have my
ocarina what am i doing I have to go
hold the phone I have to go meet with
Zelda for the first time I've got the
ocarina and I can sneak patsak past the
guards
talk to her for the first time learn the
song Zelda's Lullaby I'm going the wrong
way
didn't the minim in them how crime says
as a Lynch fan I like majora even dev
said it they've been influenced yes that
makes a lot of sense David Lynch Lynch
in very dark to my game is it's cool how
dark it is it's a it's it's a weird step
away from this the tone is so different
we were vibe in tune this guy ruined it
Lee alone they even played dopey music
[Music]
no whoo whoo you suck
okay peace out
music hmm see ya
wait no okay that's the way I sneak past
the guards am I supposed to be doing
that yet oh you know what mm-hmm
should I have gotten thinking of the
right order to do this cuz you know how
you I have to get the egg if that turns
into the chicken to wake up
melons dad male on his dad who looks
like Mario but do I need to do that
right now hmm
or should I just sneak past everyone and
come back do that later let's try to
sneak past first no I can't get into the
castle unless I wake up that guys are
that girl's dad okay I gotta go back and
get it like it where do I get the egg
where do I get the egg and on the right
path I just got to figure out how to
what to do first
[Music]
[Music]
maybe I should just go meet Epona first
Oh nothing wrong with a little hike in
Hyrule Field huh best music no that's
not true
me and max in the chat agreed earlier
gerudo valley best music you can at me
though cuz all the music in this game is
great and I would love to hear what your
favorite song is also the in the next
game Majora's Mask termina great music
wonderful me where the hell am I going
what the hell is going on there we go
yeah the brother of Mario is asleep that
dude looks like him like just airier and
he has no hat it's not Luigi either
[Music]
francisco i did talk to her in the
square now i think i'm gonna meet her
here at ron lon ranch
look at that it's dusk it's beautiful
mm-hmm and I get to meet a lifelong
friend here two of them
well first I'm gonna break their box
robbing him no you're right yeah she
does she gives me the egg after you meet
her father where do I meet him first
though asleep in front of the castle or
do I meet him in the town that I didn't
miss him this is where he hangs out
after you save him but no one's here
right now okay oh boy
okay let's just try to find a what's her
name again during the daytime I goofed
but no biggie this game you just kind of
take in it's wonderful is how you guys
remember the first time you play this
whoa no I don't have the song of the Sun
yet I don't have jack [ __ ] with my
ocarina get out of my way well I might
as well fight some because I have to
wait till sunrise anyway okay hey
should we get going
rude I'm trying to do man all right
hurry up waiting for the Sun chopping
these guys heads off yeah he is asleep
in the castle I just don't remember if I
have to uh to wake him up I gotta get
the egg but I just forget the order of
when I get the egg when I talk to her
and him who me
whoa all right I'll see target fine
come here oh man he whacked me with no
head
come on here comes the Sun getting
trampled oh they don't even give me
hearts come on
oh there's one little hearts money here
yeah all right not all bad that's on the
water
oh the Thunder meal music the is that
the windmill that songs fun
okay let's uh let's mmm let's focus here
y'all so I talked to her already
go to him first then go back out then
she'll give you the egg okay right I
have to discover he that he's asleep to
begin with I can't just go jumping
around the storyline thank you chat
liquidate thank you
okay she's right there does she give me
anything this time are you going to the
castle fairy bully fairy boy laughing
for tea heat great okay I just had to go
in and out of the marketplace got the
egg got in you have to wait a day cycle
for this thing to hatch before I can
wake his ass up thanks by the way
hmm does the Sun does time move in this
area I think it does some areas Sun just
doesn't go down only a handful though
whoop these bugs I don't have a jar but
y'all know what's up with them
[Music]
Francisco I'm really waiting for the
water temple oh man he doesn't want to
see me oh you want to see that I would
struggle come on does it turn I don't
want to wait around here if it won't
turn in tonight then I forget doesn't
appear that the Sun is moving so I'm
gonna go hatch the egg somewhere else
sneaking around the guards is fun that's
coming up very soon but right now I just
want to hatch my boy oh I love when you
wake her dad up he's like you can't wait
for that we can definitely get to that
we have 12 minutes that will probably be
one of the last things we do meeting
Zelda Zelda herself yeah yeah come on
let's go time well I can make some money
kind of hang around until the Sun Goes
Down not so average Jo and the chat says
favorite game of all time to this day
yet never seen anyone else play really
enjoying your playthrough so far
appreciate it man I wish I could play
more the stream we're playing more of
our games of the year throughout this
week today is ocarina tomorrow is GTA 3
which was our game of the year in 2001
hell yeah cannot wait and then Friday
join us cuz we will be playing sick euro
our game of the year this year is the
Sun even moving or I'm just thinking
about it too much huh come on I don't
even have bombs yet man I'm probably
gonna play this after you we cut off the
screen now I work to be
ah man no no okay that's fine
oh yeah you can make some money from
swimming in the stream here and then the
moat money come on egg hatch hatch ah
the wait all night all day all night and
I would go to Kakariko village but time
does not move in there for sure so I
would hang out there but it'll just be
dusk forever
oh yeah Evan in the chat hell yeah
ocarina is amazing I know you would
appreciate this man
crime school work this is better yeah
yeah this is work kitv's back in my day
we had blooded trees yep damn right that
was five years old head bunny actually
what is link in this game seven some
like that yeah we had buddy trees back
in my day too much
who making quick work of these fools
okay maybe not oh yeah here's the block
you guys know I love the block with this
with the shield you're just like help me
oh yeah me anyway what a worthless flock
okay
it's almost daytime my hey my egg my egg
should hatch go away the Sun is out
there we go yes the miracle of life I
doesn't even play the music that's okay
let's go wake this fool up where the
helmet
Oh quick buck here you can make a quick
buck I think you got some red rubies up
here if you do this just jump yep not
that job
I blew it you jump across the chain you
get ten bucks
forget it we have a mission to do and we
have roughly nine minutes maybe a little
more tenon and many of them don't look
at these two they don't even change in
the sequel that's the same only
animation they do ever they just spin
mm-hmm
loving life loving each other dun dun
dun dun alright don't worry I'm gonna go
save your dad that's sneak around these
fools come on let's go climb links
[Music]
Fenster
okay the other day I was playing this at
home and believe it or not I got through
every security guard without alerting a
single one
watch me go I'm probably gonna f it up
on stream it's only natural they're
gonna blow the whistle at me was there
one right up here Joe there is what
absolutely that the first guy that saw
me here oh here I was flexing on you
guys and then I blew it right from your
face oh go away
let me get to the castle look
come on I have a very important chicken
to deliver the time is boy how did I do
it those what's the optimal way to get
there
two guards there I think I've to go down
the hill a little bit that roll hey we
are playing on the Wii
we are playing on their Virtual Console
in the original lead we got component
cables hooked up to a framemeister we're
doing we're doing the damn thing is the
best it's gonna look for the Wii okay
there's a guard there hey do you guys
know um I learned this oh I think
YouTube suggested a video where if you
just stay here next to butterflies with
one of your Deku sticks or whatever
these are called I think I think that's
right they'll eventually but one of the
butterflies will eventually land on the
top here and turn into a fairy but it
takes a little bit of time and I'm
wasting time so forget it
let's go hmm
Oh Sun is going down here alright
where's I'm trying to look over this
dumb hill like an idiot okay there's two
of them I'm gonna go in the water down
below oh yeah making some money
oh man can we come up at night yeah it
should be fine I have the chicken yeah
he is passed out sleeping on the job man
get lost not to talk to you yes hello
very good Avenue while in evidence chat
water the chances yeah go go go your
daughter's all alone man left her in the
town she smart though she gave me the
egg she knew it was up alright
come on camera there we go no not climb
I lit up there we go let's get let's
sneak into the castle here huh Renaud no
this is a ocarina of time we talked
about majora's mask a little bit here
today maybe someday we'll play it but
today we're playing our game of the year
from 1998 ocarina of time ha ha liquid
no this is Mario Kart you crazy
I always hated this door cuz it doesn't
go to anywhere I'm that kind don't don't
have a door if you're not gonna make it
available okay one that seemingly looks
available it looks like you could you
can walk into that door it's centered
it's not off to the side or anything but
anyway rambling about a door here so
let's move on huh hey hey ford says
ocarina of time was more influential but
they're both great games I hear you man
shoot I gotta climb the same not Jim
wait yeah yeah sneak it in you know what
it is this dopey music means time to
evade the guards
[Music]
now man thought he was gonna go
backwards whatever I thought he was
gonna climb go up here now I have to do
you do do what if I let go AHA yeah they
don't even hear me alright what's the
pattern here mmm beautiful garden huh
let's go let's go let's go let's go no
time to talk here we go Idaho they tempt
you with those little jewel are the
rubies down there hell no bro
screaming yeah yeah no one cares
[ __ ] there you go okay almost there okay
oh shoot
come on move patrol faster oh yeah tell
your whack ass guards to step it up
Zelda woo Mashhad says best game in the
last 25 years
oh there it is you guys hear the music
you guys know that in this little window
you see portraits of like there's Yoshi
or it's Princess Peach a few others in
that window it's pretty funny
yeah there's Bowser ouija here we go
[Music]
randal hey my sidekicks I'm normally the
sidekick Persia your regular host is off
to Japan I will be taking over for the
rest of the week big shout out to her
though she set us up here she helped me
out with the thumbnail and all this
stuff she she set me up to Street for
the next three days and that great yeah
this music maybe I should just stop
talking
[Music]
do I guys alright fine
[Music]
ocarina is religion its godlike right
this is this next level this game is so
so memorable yeah one of the best OST
Zin gaming hell yeah
Gerudo Valley that's the best right max
are you still there thank you
Solid Snake would be proud of your
stealth hell yeah also that game came
out in 1998 right right yeah I think I
am mmm
yeah in North America oh yeah she hasn't
even introduced her so look at that
[Music]
sprout yeah that's me it does
okay after this we'll wrap it up a
little history of Hyrule here and some
Ganon history but we are winding down
the stream y'all keep it a secret
watch this now fine don't be a
blabbermouth
I don't say anything Linc is a silent
protagonist sort of okay
oh yeah inside the volcano that's fun
the as soon as you get that tunic yep
[Music]
ah
water temple you guys no no no no no not
today whoo I would need a guide straight
up without help
mm-hmm not nope we're just playing
little link today at the beginning of
the game I know but
[Music]
Randolf yep love this game too man thank
you for tuning in walk down memory lane
together yes
crime I'm gonna download it when I get
home good luck I think on the Wii is a
no-go the Wii U is that virtual shop
down I don't remember it might be find a
way to play it the 3ds version or or if
you downloaded this originally on the
Wii like I did
I just never deleted it but I hope you
can get a chance to play crime somehow
some way the door of time yep I don't
even walk into the temple of time I just
eat right past it
ah man iconic
yeah you guys yep I'm just gonna say yes
[Music]
okay good
crime you have the 3ds version go home
and play please this is I want to keep
playing do I want to look again and I
guess so candid dork oh I can't believe
that Hyrule has even a low level
relationship with this scum look at him
sitting there thinking about that final
fight in this game is wonderful it's so
cool and you need the Master Sword to do
it that's fun too like you can't even
use the gore on swords like nope if you
want to end this game you got to do it
right with the Master Sword oh we saw me
[Music]
[Music]
there's a little longer than I thought
we are gonna wrap after this though
appreciate you guys for tuning in
of course this is like when I get the
ocarina of time but we had a good run
today this was fun having you guys all
here makes it worth it so fun look at
her worried little face we can I don't
believe you
[Music]
[Music]
that's right just admiring the music
here oh the letter the letter that gets
me through the the gate
what Zelda's autographed love it yeah
yeah making such a big deal dunno that
Zelda though that's that's how you do it
alright that's gonna do it for us today
you guys let me switch over here to see
if I got it down watch this I do it yeah
thank you guys for tuning in
I'm Ritchie I'll be back tomorrow to
play a little gta3 that was our game of
the year in 2001 thank you for tuning in
today and I'll see you back here
tomorrow
link quit yawning relax dude bye
[Music]
[Music]